the left trots out student says their
point people everything is about race
and the media spin wildly for gun
control in every possible direction i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
so there's our last day of the week
until Friday broadcasting from Los
Angeles and we're headed off to
Washington DC for CPAC I will have some
notes on CPAC because a little bit of
controversy is broken out about one of
the invited speakers suffice it to say I
disagree with the invitation but I also
don't control the invites I am looking
forward to seeing everyone at CPAC
however before we get to any of that
plus the news of the day first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Zeile so if you are in need of some
relaxation if your back aches if your
neck aches if you've been working too
hard
Zeile is the thing for you so Z EE L
okay this is a massage service it's an
in-home massage service everyone loves
massage people don't get them because
instead yeah you have to go over to the
spa you have to wait for an appointment
you have to shell out a lot of money to
do it and then the quality than that
great well what Zeile does is they send
a licensed masseuse directly to your
house the masseuse brings the table the
oils the candle like the whole deal and
they turn your home into the spa I have
gotten it as a president for my wife
I've gotten it as a present for my
in-laws I've gotten it for my sister
I've gotten it for my parents it is a
fantastic gift and it is great for you
as well they can do it basically on a
moment's notice go to zeal comm or seals
iPhone or Android app @ze Elcom and
select from top local licensed
pre-screened massage therapists choose
your favorite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage seven days a week 365 days a
year
as the Oh massage therapist can be at
your door in as little as an hour
privacy convenience quality and comfort
that's what you get with your massage on
demand with zeal again they have nine
thousand licensed massage therapists
with a massage table I know my family's
used a bunch of different masseuse is
from zeal they are all fantastic there's
a reason why they're a fast-growing
company to help you get started our
listeners can get twenty five dollars
off their first massage by using the
promo code been at checkouts when you
check out make sure you use that promo
code bending at 25 bucks off it gets
even better if you sign up for zeals
massage membership and get 20% off all
your massages plus a free massage table
and sheet set that is a $380 value yours
free there's no initiation fee to join
there's just a great additional savings
on top of the $25 discount you're gonna
get when you use promo code bed so go to
Zeile again that ze e Elcom or on seals
iPhone or Android app and then make sure
to add click add promo code to checkout
and use my promo code Ben and get 25
bucks off your first in-home on-demand
massage or sign up for the massage
membership and get 20% off all massages
Plus that free massage table and sheet
set a $380 value fantastic company again
can't recommend it more highly for a
gift particularly the loved ones zeal
comm you shouldn't get gifts for people
you don't love anyway so you just get it
for a loved one seal calm and use that
promo code Ben so that they know that we
sent you alright so the debate over gun
control continues and as I said
yesterday I think there are some things
that we actually can do right there is
what is called they've been called the
the gun violence restraining order this
is something that I talked about
yesterday David French at National
Review spoke about the possibility of
having laws on the books that allow
immediate family or close friends to go
to the court and petition to have your
capacity to own a gun temporarily
removed from you if a court finds that
you are a threat to yourself or others
that would be a useful measure in my
view another useful measure would be
dramatically heightening security I
talked about this on Fox and Friends
this morning I've talked about it this
week the idea here would be that you
have to harden the defenses around
schools our banks have tremendous
security there's no reason why our
dollars should be guarded more closely
than our children there's been a lot of
talk about arming teachers and some
people object to this well I don't
understand why a trained armed teacher
would be a threat to your child you
trust your child in the classroom with
that teacher every single day and right
now we are leaving teachers at the at
the whim of mass killers there is that
coach in Parkland to a shot to death
while he was attempting to defend
students wouldn't have been better if he
actually been licensed to carry a
handgun and had a gun with him so he
maybe could have done something about it
that they should build schools sure from
now on they should build schools with
failsafe mechanisms so that if a mass
shooter were to enter the school there
were there'd be a capacity to actually
lock down separate parts of the school
they have this lockdown capacity at a
lot of hospitals there's no reason why
they shouldn't use it when it comes to
schools as well and another thing that
that ought to be done is something that
we here are now doing at Daily wire so
at daily wire as I've said on the show I
said it on the last in the last week
that I wasn't gonna name the shooter on
the show I wasn't gonna show pictures of
the shooter on the show and somebody
emailed me and said well then why is
your website naming the shooter and
showing pictures and I thought well
that's a good point and so we at Daily
wire will no longer be showing the names
or the faces of mass shooters the reason
being that studies tens show that mass
shooters are driven by a need for media
attention and so this time we are going
to try to be part of the solution rather
than part of the problem the media that
the race
show faces the race to show names in the
media is obviously ratings driven it's
obviously clique driven because people
are curious people want to know what the
guy looks like a lit and showed up a
school we're not gonna be part of that
game because we can give you all the
relevant information as we have been
doing on the show we've told you who the
guy is we've told you everything about
him we've told you what you need to know
for the public policy debate we're just
not going to put a name and a face on
him because we don't want to give him
any sort of uh notoriety we don't want
him to be unintentionally given levels
of exposure that will drive the next
mass killer there's no reason why we
should know the names of mass shooters
particularly except out of just normal
human curiosity or why their picture
should be flashed across the news we can
give you all the information that you
need to know without that pictorial
evidence behind it the reason we're
doing this is because there are a series
of studies that have shown again the
mass shooters tend to feed off media
attention so professor Jennifer Johnston
and Andrew joy of Western New Mexico
University found in a paper presented to
the APA that's the American
Psychological Association in 2016 quote
media contagion can help make mass
shootings more common unfortunately
Johnston says we find that a
cross-cutting trait among many profiles
of mass shooters is desire for fame they
say that the rise of such a trait in
mass shooters rose quote in
correspondents the emergence of
widespread 24-hour news coverage on
cable news programs and the rise of the
internet during the same period
so Johnston recommended a media pack to
no longer share reproduce or retweet the
names faces or long-winded statements of
killers so that we don't see it as so
that we could see a dramatic reduction
in mass shootings in one to two years so
some studies say that the the dramatic
reduction won't be that dramatic but
there is a similar conclusion which is
that a lot of these shooters are driven
by the need for fame so we're gonna do
our part again we can give you all the
details that you need to know without
speaking the name of the person who did
it because again there's a lot of people
out there who want the world to know
their name well we're not going to help
them in that quest that's not something
that we think is is a worthwhile is a
worthwhile thing the media of course are
not going a lot of other outlets in the
media are not going to do this
unfortunately cable news is not going to
do this CNN shows the names and face of
the shooters Fox News shows the names
and face of the shooter
The Washington Post New York Times all
the major outlets I believe still show
the names and faces of mass shooters
because they said the public has a right
to know well just because you have a
right to know doesn't mean that I have I
have
obligations to show you and I do not
feel the obligation to show you the face
of a shooter outweighs my obligation as
a human being to prevent the
dissemination of material that helps
possibly create the next shooter that's
not something that I want to be a part
of okay so speaking of media malfeasance
and the left's malfeasance on the gun
control issue and the fact that every
mass shooting now has become a cause
celeb that that this has become the club
to wield against gun law-abiding gun
owners then the media have really done
an outsized job here so I just want to
show you some of the things the media
have been doing because they're truly
insane so ABC News had a tape of a guy
named Scott Pappalardo you've never
heard of Scott Pappalardo Scott
Pappalardo is some dude who they found
on Facebook why are they putting him on
ABC News's Twitter feed well because
he's a gun owner and he decided to
destroy his gun for some odd reason here
here's a video of him talking about it
my pre ban legally registered ar-15
which I purchased over 30 years ago
now I'm a firm believer in the Second
Amendment and I even have it tattooed on
my arm a lot of people have said to me
what do you need to own a weapon like
that for its only purpose is to kill and
I'll be honest it's a lot of fun to
shoot
I remember after Sandy Hook happened I
said to my wife I'd gladly give this gun
up if it would save the life of just one
child
I've decided today I'm gonna make sure
this weapon will never be able to take a
life the barrel of this gun will never
be pointed at someone is the right to
own this weapon more important in
someone's life a weapon like this that
can cause so much death and destruction
and then he goes ahead and he takes a
saw and he proceeds to saw the gun in
half essentially so he he actually walks
out there you can see him doing this
routine there's so many of them out
there now okay so so first point here is
that what he actually just did is sort
of he legally sawed off long weapons and
make them into shorter weapons second of
all it's stupid the reason that stupid
is because that gun was not going to be
used to shoot it I mean it's been in his
hands for thirty years has it ever been
used to shoot a child has it ever been
used to shoot anyone listen would I be
willing to give up my Mossberg 500 and
my not a 9-millimeter Glock would I be
willing to give those guns up to save
the life of a child sure I'd be willing
to give those guns up to save a life of
a child right you have a guy standing
next to me he sent me to shoot this
child unless you give up your guns
obviously I give up the guns it's a
no-brainer but that's not the choice
that's a false choice my guns are not
going to be used to kill the child and
nobody is blackmailing me to give up my
guns or they're going to shoot a child
that gun had never been used in anger
against another human being and this guy
seems like a decent fellow my
presumption is that if he saw a shoot of
mass shooting taking place you'd go grab
his gun and try to take down the mass
shooter he wouldn't go and join the mass
shooter but this is the false binary
that's been created every gun is the
threat that gun was not a threat because
the guy who owns the gun is not a threat
my gun is not a threat it's locked up in
my safe my gun is only a threat to
somebody who would harm my fan
hurt people I love and this is true for
the vast vast 99.9% of law-abiding gun
owners this is the truth for and yet the
media pushed this out as though this is
some sort of great act of heroism
Olympic gold in virtue signaling for
Scott Pappalardo who made no one safer
in this act
no one was made safer in this act but he
got his name on the news and then he's
got to put out this sort of propaganda
which I guess is very exciting I'm gonna
show you some more media malfeasance on
the gun control issue in just a second
plus we still have to get to the
Children's Crusade which is something
that the left is now pushing first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Tommy John so there is no better
time to upgrade from your old
uncomfortable underwear to Tommy John
which is the revolutionary Comfort
company for the modern man and when you
switch to Tommy John you're not going to
switch to any other underwear company
not because it is just a fantastic pair
of underwear but also because it is
affordable also because that they last
forever I mean they really hold up when
you send them through the wash their
unparalleled comfort innovative designs
patented fabrics to ensure that your
underwear will never ride up the
waistband never rolls down and you will
never get a wedgie I had enough of those
in high school I don't need anymore
and Tommy John ensures that that never
happens again it's the best pair of
guarantee if you don't love it on you
then it's on them and it's free Tommy
John re-engineered underwear so you
never have to adjust you never have to
sit around picking at your underwear
I've tried all kinds of different
underwear brands Tommy John is the best
there is and that I can guarantee
they've even taken their Comfort
expertise and applied it to the rest of
your apparel so Tommy John's has
undershirts that stay tucked in socks
that never fall down which is a big
thing
second skin tees that are so soft you
won't believe it and a choice of smart
fabrics for every situation or outfit so
if you're looking for undergarments of
any kind Tommy John is the place to go
and again their underwear is backed by
the best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free guarantees you have nothing to lose
Tommy John no adjustment even go to
Tommy John comm / Shapiro and their
special offer offer for our listeners
Tommy John's comm / repair you get 20%
off your first order that's Tommy John
comm / Shapiro and you get 20% off again
Tommy John comm / capiro you get the
best underwear you've ever had you get
20% off his underwear and get some let
them know that we sent you as well okay
back to the media coverage of the gun
control issue the media obviously have a
deep and abiding agenda it says in the
media as I say what's something the
media could do to actually help prevent
shootings according to studies they
could what we're doing over at Daily
wire not mention the name or face of the
shooters
that they could do they're not doing
that so instead what they do is they put
out a bunch of people talking about how
gun control is obviously the thing that
has to happen you're so CNN is having
the entire special I believe it's
tomorrow night and that special tomorrow
night is going to feature all of the
students over at Parkland basically
talking about why they want gun control
and the reason this is stayed in the
news is because the media have decided
to use the children over at Parkland in
order to push their agenda I will talk
about whether it is moral to use
children in order to push an agenda
teenagers to push an agenda in just a
second but first I'm going to show you
some more elements in the news that are
just plain false that are just fake news
so CBS News put out this promo saying
that in Florida it's easier to buy an
assault rifle than it is to obtain cold
medicine this is just not true
says here's what's more difficult to
purchase than agonda in Florida sudafed
contains pseudoephedrine which can be
legally manufactured can be used to
legally manufacture methamphetamines
federal regulations require it be sold
behind the pharmacy or service counter
and customers need to show they're over
18 years of age and then it says
customers are limited to purchases of
nine grams per month about 215 dose
boxes of 24-hour claritin-d or 310 those
boxes of leave cold and sinus or 624
dose boxes of sudafed in florida you can
buy as many guns as you want at one time
according to the NRA S Institute for
legislative action right there's no
federal background check for cold
medicine there's no federal background
check for sudafed it says you don't need
a permit to purchase a rifle or shotgun
right but there is a federal background
check that happens in every federally
licensed firearms dealer says there are
restrictions on the amounts of
fertilizer one can purchase because
ammonium nitrate when mixed with other
substances can become explosive right
because you don't have a right to
explosives you do have a right to keep
and bear arms for your own safety but
the headline here that it's easier to
buy a gun than it is to buy claritin-d
is just not true try buying claritin-d
go to a pharmacy try to buy claritin-d
it is much easier to buy claritin-d than
it is to go to a gun shop and buy a gun
you have to you in California you
actually have to take a test in
California insider' in other states you
don't in Florida you have to have a
federal background check they check you
through the system that doesn't happen
with cold medicine by the way I think
from a libertarian perspective there's a
solid argument that I should be able to
buy as much sudafed as I wanted a given
shot and I'm not sure that the
government has a place in regulating how
much sudafed I can buy so I have
problems
with that on a libertarian basis just
automatically I don't know I should have
to go back to the store every so often
to buy sudafed if I just want to stock
up and use it later and if I'm producing
meth and the government can bust me and
the government can prosecute me but
again this is the media pushing
falsehoods the again the idea that it's
difficult to buy guns that it's easier
to to buy lots of other things in the
United States than it is to buy a gun
just not true if you're doing it legally
through a federally licensed firearms
dealer that's not the only piece of
propaganda being put out cNN has
commentator named gagliano and and this
this person says that gun pal says that
sorry it's James gagliano who's the FBI
Supervisory Special Agent retired and
says that the founding fathers never
could have envisioned an
eighteen-year-old kid
buying a buying a gun vented gunpowder
and 700 AD the first guns were mid 14th
century invented the 1791 the Second
Amendment comes online and here we are
in 2018 and we're hanging on to this and
we're going we just can't talk about
this because if we do that were somehow
gonna tick off the founding fathers the
founding fathers could not envision that
a 18 year old kid could go into a gun
store he can't buy beer but he could buy
a semi-automatic weapon and it's a
weapon award David spoke about this okay
this is absolute sheer nonsense the
founding fathers were fully aware that
18 year-old kids could buy weapons of
war who do you think was in the American
Revolutionary Army what the Founding
Fathers would mostly be shocked by his
regulations on age of consent to buy
beer they would be like wait a second
you have to be 18 to get a beer you have
to get it you have to be 18 to get an
ale around here what kind of nonsense is
that there are people in the Arab
volusia nari army who are 14 years old
15 years old if you actually go and
watch Mel Gibson's movie the patriot
there are a lot of kids in there the
reason they're in there is because that
was true there were a lot of kids who
are in the American Revolutionary Army
and by the way virtually everybody in
the United States at the time of the
founding owned a weapon and brought it
home and then they would drill on the
green together as part of a
well-regulated militia but it was
personal gun ownership
everyone owned a gun back in the day
including people who were young eighteen
year old kids by the way we're not kids
in the 1791 in 1791 18 year old people
were expected to be looking to get
married and have a family already we're
only considering 18
kids because this is our modern society
where 18 year olds are considered kids
except if they have something to say
about gun control in which case we
consider them adults as we'll get to in
just a second that's not the end of the
propaganda Symone Sanders commentator on
MSNBC said well you know what this is
really about is race because everything
is always about race invariably and
always everything is about race so
favorite talk we wouldn't be talking
about the types of legislation we could
and could not make happen because if he
was yelling I'll Allah Akbar Congress
and the president one would have been
tweeting about it they would have
swooped in and did okay
ok Bill Kristol here actually doing
yeoman's work is on CNN on MSNBC of
course he's exactly right that's him
saying we didn't change any of the gun
laws after San Bernardino we didn't
change any of the gun laws after the
orlando massacre and it's worth noting
that when everybody says well there was
a muslim man after that
well you're messing up the time line
okay san bernardino happened that the
San Bernardino shooting was I believe in
2015 that was two years before any
Muslim ban was actually attempted right
and it wasn't a Muslim ban anyway
there's a travel ban from particular
countries the vast majority of Muslims
all over the world can still get into
the United States the the same thing is
true of the Orlando shooting not one gun
law was changed as a result of those
shootings but there are attempting to
demagogue the issues because again these
issues must be demagogued according to
the left the reason that the issues are
demagogues is because the left wants to
push this notion that anyone who
disagrees with them is a bad person
David Brooks has a good column on this
over at the New York Times it's rare
that I recommend to David Brooks column
because he's the in-house can one of the
in-house conservatives over at the New
York Times which means he's not
particularly conservative he's a fan of
gun control but what he said today is
basically correct but the left is
fighting angry over it they are spitting
mad over this what David Brooks said
today was he said many of us have walked
this emotional path we may end up doing
more harm than good if there's one thing
we've learned it is the guns who become
a cultural flashpoint in a nation that
is unequal and divided the people who
defend gun rights believe that snobbish
elites look down on their morals and
want to destroy their culture if we end
up telling such people that they and
their
are despicable they will just despise us
back and dig in their heels so if you
want to stop school shootings it's not
enough just event and march it's
necessary to let people from red america
lead the way and to show respect to gun
owners at all points there has to be
trust and respect first then we can
strike a compromise on guns as guns and
not some sacred cross in the culture war
this of course is a hundred percent true
one of the reasons that no agreement has
been reached here is that gun owners
will say why don't we talk about these
issues that have nothing to do with guns
and less will say I don't want to talk
about any of those issues you're just
doing that because you wanted to strap
from guns and the right will say gun
owners will say to the left well the
only reason you want to talk about guns
is cuz you hate guns it's not because
you actually think this is gonna prevent
school shootings you've provided no
evidence that this will prevent school
shootings other than a mass gun
confiscation like a regime in Australia
or Britain where the sample size is too
small to really identify it anyway the
number of school shootings in Australia
prior to the gun ban the gun
confiscation the gun buyback program was
so low that when it went to zero that is
within margin of error but the left has
a real stake in avoiding the
consequences of having real discussions
about real issues and the right knows
that people on the right gun owners feel
insulted by this as well they should
when ABC shows that video of that guy
cutting his gun in half and then
suggests to me a law-abiding gun owner
than if I were a good person I would saw
my gun in half my answer is no if I were
a good person I would maintain my gun
keep it in good working condition and
shoot bad guys when they attempt to
shoot innocent people it's always the
cops who take down these folks by the
way it's always people with guns who
take down mass shooters it is always the
threat of another gun that stops a mass
shooter in the end that's why it's so
foolish to to cast doubt on all
law-abiding gun owners now you want to
talk about measures that you can take
because you think that they are
reasonable with regard to buying guns
and owning guns you're gonna have to
show number one how that connects to the
issue at hand school shootings and
number two you're gonna have to explain
why it why it is that gun violence in
the United States has been dramatically
declining for the last two decades
despite skyrocketing numbers of guns in
circulation in the United States the
rate of gun ownership has gone down
overall I believe among among households
but the number of guns in the United
States on an absolute level has gone up
pretty tremendously over the last 20
years
meanwhile the the rate of gun violence
is going
the absolute number of guns were
supposed to be a good measure of how
much gun violence was taking place it
simply is not it just isn't but in their
in their drive their desire to ignore
the evidence in front of them and the
left seeks to to avoid the consequences
of these discussions and and instead
they cast aspersions and people on the
right when people on the right say guys
we're all on the same side here people
in let's say no we're not because the
NRA kills people and then they vidalias
week yesterday asking how many people
the NRA had killed today how many
children the inner eye had killed today
the answer is zero there's not one
documented case of a mass shooter being
a member of the NRA but doesn't matter
you know who cares New York Daily News
ran that headline hey hey NRA how many
kids did you kill today again the answer
is zero that's it but yeah but when
we're never gonna hear conversations by
the way about organizations that
actually do kill children like Planned
Parenthood how many kids do they kill
today well on average they kill about a
thousand children a day that thousand
unborn children a day so that seems like
a good place to start if you're gonna
talk about dead kids because of
organizations not the NRA okay we're
gonna get to the student crusade the
Children's Crusade in just a second and
whether we should listen to the children
whether the children should lead us
because this is the new pitch from the
left first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at texture so the
reporting in this day and age from from
full-scale magazines has become really
really good the New York of course broke
the Weinstein scandal Vanity Fair does a
lot of really excellent reporting the
Atlantic has a lot of good foreign
policy reporting these days well it's
very expensive to subscribe to each of
these magazines in turn instead what you
should do is get the texture app it
delivers unlimited access to over 200
premium magazines and right now you can
try texture for free the texture app is
here to help you and we're talking about
the most popular magazines we are
talking about the most read magazines
and the most informational magazines as
well we're talking about time Vanity
Fair in New York magazine we're talking
about ESPN The Magazine if you're a
sports fan we're talking about Sports
Illustrated we're talking about National
Geographic basically if you have a
magazine that you enjoy reading there is
a good shot that it's going to be a
member of texture there's a really good
shot that you're going to that you're
going to be able to access it through
texture calm so go start your text or
free trial right now texture calm slash
pen and if you choose to continue
podcast listeners get extra for just
$9.99
that's 30% off they're listed price
again that's texture calm and you get
then when you use the /bin you get the
entire app for $9.99 a month which is
30% off they're listed price and you get
to try it for free you get a free trial
so go again texture comm slash pen and
start your free trial today never get
bored waiting around at the airport at
the bus stop never get bored sitting
around waiting for your wife to arrive
home for dinner yeah she's been working
late lately that's what texture calm /
bun is for so go over there grab the app
and make her life more in if you're an
information junkie the way I am you
can't afford to live without a textured
comm slash pen again free trial plus you
get you get texture for $9.99 a month
this is all your favorite magazines back
issues Anytime Anywhere texture comm and
again using that /ban okay so the left
has been calling now for a Children's
Crusade they know they've been making
these gun control arguments consistently
for a long time and they know that these
gun control arguments have not been
particularly effective the gun control
laws have not been put on the books the
gun control laws that are on the books
have not really been enforced well so
now the left is looking for new
spokespeople because they figure that it
can't be the message that's wrong it
can't be that the American people don't
particularly like the message it has to
be something else and what it probably
is is that we've been using the wrong
messengers the messengers that we truly
need in this crusade our children as you
know this is a pet peeve of mine when
Jimmy Kimmel trotted out his small child
his baby who has no political views from
what I can see to talk about Obamacare
and suggested that his child's heart
surgery at Children's Hospital if dr.
Vaughn Starnes was an excuse for
maintaining Obamacare I said that this
was immoral I said it was immoral
because my daughter had the same surgery
at the same hospital at the same well a
different surgery but in open heart
surgery same hospital the same doctor
this did not confer expertise upon me
regarding Obamacare you actual have to
study the issues I objected when
Democrats under President Obama would
routinely trot out children and use
children's letters as an excuse to talk
about public policy this is a lot on
guns they would find a letter in the
mail from seven-year-old probably
written by mommy and daddy about gun
control
well I can't we just make all the guns
go away and it's really interesting the
other day I was at my parents brought
over a box of old papers and stuff I'd
had from when I was a little kid and I
went to a public school and I found a
paper in there that I'd written when I
was maybe six or seven years old and the
entire thing was about environmental
and how human beings are ruining the
environment and the reason that I was
writing that paper when I was 6 or 7
years old is because this is basically
what they teach in public school they
teach you that you're supposed to care
about the environment which is fine but
then they teach you that man is ruining
the environment mad responsible for the
death of all the geese this is the
routine that they teach you in public
school it's not necessarily true in fact
the facts don't tend to back up the idea
that human beings are solely responsible
for degradation in in every aspect of
the environment in many ways environment
has gotten better in the last few
decades but this is what I was writing
when I was in when I was 7 should I have
been deciding gun policy probably not
because what I'd probably be parroting
is what I'd heard from my teachers and
from my parents because this is what
children do adults teach children and
then children parent what the adults
have to say because they think adults
are smart it's only later when children
become adults that they realize that
adults are just as stupid as kids most
of the time one of the great
disappointments of being an adult is
realizing that all the people who have
houses in cars are just the same stupid
kids but a little bit more mentally
developed that said let don't turn
adults and children are children but
because there are a bunch of high school
kids who are now speaking out about gun
control and the media wants to confer
upon them virtue the media wants to
confer upon them the capacity for for
leadership it's it's quite it's quite
shocking and quite fascinating and quite
stupid so here as I showed you before is
these these kids chanting hey hey NRA
how many kids did you kill today from
the New York Daily News I don't know if
we actually it's it so they did that and
then there was a picture of all these
kids lying in front of the White House
because you know that means something if
children lie in front of the White House
that makes a difference if it's 17 year
olds lying from the White House that
makes a difference there's a hot there
was a kid named David hog who is
apparently according to his Twitter feed
he was you know pro-gun control long
before this happened which doesn't
change anything he just suggests that he
had a political agenda and so as a
political agenda wasn't like he was
pro-gun and then flipped because of what
he saw in front of him you know new
evidence changing his position this is
always his position but David hog he
came out and was ripping anybody who has
taken money from the NRA and of course
being treated with full seriousness by
the anchors on this show even though
there is no there there's no credibility
to the actual words that this human
being is speaking Emma Gonzalez another
shooting survivor doing the same thing
we would hope that you have the decent
morality to support us at this point and
not take money from people that want to
keep what lessening gun legislation and
making it even easier for these
horrifying people to get guns because if
you can't get elected without taking
money from child murderers why are you
running and there's Alison Cammarata
kind of shaking their hand softly hit
her head softly and and giving full
credibility to idiotic comments like
this I'm sorry whether it's said by
seventeen-year-old or whether it's said
by a 35 year old stupid comments or
stupid comments this is a stupid comment
if you can't say what are the child
murders that he's talking about is it
Isis who are the child murderers is it
Planned Parenthood
notes the NRA and the NRA gives money to
politicians because they think that the
politicians are going to support gun
rights one of the means that was going
around yesterday that is an absolute
falsehood it's an absolute lie there was
a meme going around yesterday suggesting
that the NRA had paid for the gun
training of this kid know what of the of
the shooter know what actually happened
is that the NRA gave money to the Junior
ROTC which is a training program for
future military members JROTC is a
fantastic program ROTC is a great
program okay this kid where the shooter
this terrible human being
went to some of these shooting programs
with JROTC and the media ran with this
as NRA had a training program for the
kid that's not remotely true that's not
true that's what the media was was
pushing because again the message
matters more than the actual truth of
message and just because these kids
experience pain and suffering our heart
squats them for experiencing pain and
suffering but it doesn't mean that what
they're saying makes any sons lots of
people experience pain and suffering
yeah Jim Garrity was making this point
yesterday with regard to the Jersey the
Jersey Girls these are the women who
whose husbands were lost in 9/11 they
were very radically left and they were
conferred what what some people on the
left side he was Maureen Dowd suggested
was absolute moral authority give them
absolute moral authority now there's no
such thing as absolute moral authority
for any statement either a statement is
true or a statement is false moral
authority means nothing you don't have
moral moral authority to say something
simply because you suffered the question
is whether what you are saying is
effective and truthful and whether it
forwards a proper agenda for the
American people not whether you have
personally suffered and doing
so lots of people have personally
suffered and then do terrible things it
doesn't mean that they're allowed to do
terrible things or say terrible things
personal suffering does not make
something more legitimate it's a it's a
real pet peeve of mine but what what
Garrity was pointing out is that the
Jersey Girls were treated with this
tremendous respect by the media they
would go on national television shows
and say things like it was an inside job
like 9/11 was an inside job there were
certain members of the Jersey girls who
said that and members of the media would
give exactly the reaction you're seeing
from Alison cammarata they're the kind
of shake head serious tone like
pretending that this is okay what you're
saying just because you went through
something terrible are you going through
something terrible doesn't make what you
say anymore or less true it's either
true or it's not but again the left has
an agenda here and the agenda here is to
put up the most sympathetic face as
possible in order to push an agenda that
the left already wants as I said
yesterday cnn's town hall they're
holding tomorrow night with regard to
gun control I don't remember them doing
the same thing after the Boston Marathon
bombing I don't remember them doing the
same thing after San Bernardino at least
not for people who are stumping for a
travel ban they would never do the same
thing with regard to people who are
looking for better screening of illegal
immigrants I remember them doing a panel
with Kate Steinle family talking about
why we need Kate's law why the instead
they push stories about sanctuary cities
every day one of the things that happens
in the media that people tend to ignore
is selection bias o CN n will say yes we
covered the pro-gun control the pro-gun
control position and the anti gun
control position yes but how did you
cover it what stories did you choose to
cover Fox News is biased in a particular
way because they choose what they want
to put on TV and CNN is biased in a
particular way because they choose what
they want to put on TV the segments that
you choose to put on TV are just as
important as how those segments are
actually presented so CNN spending
blanket coverage on a bunch of students
who don't know anything about gun
control or gun laws or or the the
efficacy of various proposals being
trotted out because they're sympathetic
faces
I just find really disheartening it gets
even worse than that in a second I'm
going to show you what a Harvard Law
Professor Lawrence tribe was gone
completely crazy had to say about what
he called the so-called Children's
Crusade
but for that you're gonna have to go
over to Daley we're calm and subscribe
so for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscriptions daily wire.com you get the
rest of this show live the rest of
Michael Moses show live the rest of the
Andrew Clavin show live I released an
interview with Andrew yes
on our channel she'd give it a listen
and you should really go subscribe to
Drew's show because it really is worth
the listen he's excellent at breaking
down narrative and and his show is
really good but if you want to subscribe
to it fully you go to daily we're calm
and for $9.99 a month you get these
subscription also if you get all those
things gonna be part of our mail bags
all the rest you get this the very best
in all beverage vessels leftist tears
hot or cold tumblr off look at the glory
emanating from this a mere piece of
metal and yet the genius of design the
capacity for holding liquid unparalleled
so you get all of that for $99 ear which
is cheaper than the monthly subscription
if you want to listen later for free go
to iTunes SoundCloud subscribe to our
channel over at YouTube we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
or and conservative podcast in the
nation
so Harvard professor Lawrence tribe is
pushing what he calls now a Children's
Crusade and what this crusade is is
letting the children speak for us now
it's always interesting to watch as
folks on the Left tried out children in
support of certain propositions but not
others so if we had for example a bunch
of fifteen-year-old girls said listen I
think that we should cut back on
pornography pornography is really bad
it's it's turning boys into pervs it
makes boys more likely to treat us badly
well we need is a crusade against
pornography across the country and then
all of a sudden it would be these kids
don't know what they're talking about
these public policy experts really like
fifteen-year-old girls come on when you
talk about children when whenever people
in the pro-life movement show pictures
of aborted babies nor show pictures of
non aborted babies and they say this is
what you are killing then it turns into
how dare you use children as a crutch
for your argument even though it's
children's lives that are really at
stake they're calling this gun control
March they're they're playing gun
control March for March 24th and they're
calling it the March for our lives if
they're really the thing about the
unborn is they can't have a March for
their lives because by definition they
are unborn but the March for our life is
really stupid the at least in a way that
its terms you March for whatever you
want it's a free country but the
terminology marched for our lives is
silly because nobody is suggesting that
they want you to die the march for civil
rights mattered because there are a lot
of people who wanted to actively deprive
you of civil rights I don't know a
single person in the United States
outside of some evil mass shooters who
actually wants to deprive any of these
kids of their lives their liberty or
their pursuit of happiness I don't know
anyone in the United States who actually
wants to do that we're all talking about
different ways to assure that these kids
can be protected even if the left
refuses to acknowledge that fact
Lawrence tribe because he's so eager to
to push the idea that kids can lead us a
child shall lead us he suggested quote
teens between 14 and 18 have far better
BS detectors on average than adults 18
and older this is certainly not true
this is certainly not true if that were
true it would not be easy to get kids
who are 14 to smoke pot kids who are 14
are dumb okay I speak to lots of kids
who are 14 at some point my daughter
will be I remember being 14 kids between
14 are 8 and 18 when I say they're dumb
I don't mean they don't have the
capacity to be smart I mean they
literally have underdeveloped brains
okay brain science suggests the brain
does not stop developing until you are
your prefrontal cortex which is the part
of your brain that is responsible for
higher function it's the part of your
brain that is basically the brakes on
your amygdala your amygdala is your
emotional response center that is really
over developed when you're a teenager
and then your prefrontal cortex because
it's underdeveloped it doesn't stop you
from doing stuff so you say hey car
surfing your MiG's let goes car surfing
that sounds awesome that'll be fun an
adrenaline yeah and then your prefrontal
cortex when you're adult goes right but
your you'll die and that's stupid when
you're a teenager the prefrontal cortex
goes well maybe and then you do
something dumb there's a reason that
sixteen-year-old drivers are the worst
drivers on the road and there's a reason
the teenagers make the worst sexual
decisions imaginable there's a reason
that teenagers make dumb life decisions
about drugs teenagers are not known as a
typical matter especially in our in our
infantilizing era where we don't
actually confirm responsibility on
children in that infantilizing era kids
are not capable of making good public
policy decisions as a general rule it's
not necessarily true for every
individual but it is certainly true as a
broad generality which is why the age of
consent in most states is 16 years old
or higher it is why the age for voting
is 18 years old there's a good case to
be made it should be raised back to 21
based on modern brain science but anyway
Lawrence tribe says wouldn't it be great
if the voting age were lowered to 16
just a pipe dream I know but Children's
Crusade a couple notes about the
Children's Crusade if he's talking about
the original Children's Crusade which
took place in the 13th century that was
a giant fail the idea there was that a
bunch of children were going to go to
the Middle East and they were going to
convince all of the Muslims in the
Middle East to become Christian or at
least give up control over Jerusalem it
ended variably by various accounts with
the enslavement of thousands of children
or with them becoming homeless on the
streets of Rome so that was giant fail
if you're talking about Martin Luther
King's Children's Crusade in which a
bunch of children marched for civil
rights the idea there was to demonstrate
just how evil the anti-civil rights
forces were by showing Bull Connor
sticking dogs on eight-year-old children
it's so that there's I mean honestly
there are some question there are some
questions about whether it's moral to do
that really but it's it but not not the
singing of the dogs that is immoral
there are questions about what it is it
is moral to put children in the line of
fire to to push even a useful political
agenda but at least there was a use here
if there are Children's Crusade now for
gun control which apparently there's
going to be no one is going to
then no one is stopping these kids from
lying down and getting on TV and making
whatever point they want to make but the
left has a very bifurcated view of when
children are responsible for their
actions so when children parrot the left
agenda then all of a sudden they're
responsible for their actions when they
don't parent the left agenda then they
are not responsible for their actions
that's the way that this works on the
Left it's constantly pushing more sexual
autonomy for youngsters they say that
laws restricting minors access to
abortion and contraceptives are
unconstitutional that children have a
capacity to declare themselves men or
women even if they are members of the
opposite sex and that they should go
through gender transitioning regardless
of what their parents have to say this
week a judge in Ohio ruled that a
custody of the 17 year old girl who's
suffering from gender dysphoria should
be handed over to her grandparents
rather than her parents because she
wanted become a boy and her parents said
no no that logic is likely to be
utilized more rather than less in the
future but the same people who say that
children are fully capable of making
grown people decisions they will say
that the legal age for gun purchases
should be raised to 21 so you want to
lower the voting age to 16 but you want
to increase the the purchase gun of the
gun purchase age to 21 weird how that
works if kids are so good at stuff if
kids are so capable of making fully
grown people decisions then why would
you then why would you not lower the age
of consent for buying a gun to 16 after
all these kids have far better BS
detectors on average than adults
they're more responsible than adults
apparently they're really good at things
so why shouldn't we have a Children's
Crusade
let's arm up all the kids I mean if the
kids are the ones who are the mode the
best among us but of course the left
doesn't want to do that so they want to
they want to say that 16 year olds
should vote why because when you're 16
you're on the left and then they want to
say that 16 year olds should not be able
to drink or have a gun so responsibility
without any accountability as I guess
the order of the day these are the same
folks who suggest by the way that
children are disadvantaged if they are
not on their parents health insurance
until they're 26 years old they actually
say that the criminal justice system
should try you as a juvie
until you're 25 because it's not until
your mid-20s that your brain finally
reaches complete maturity so which is it
our kids fully autonomous agents or our
kids actually innocents to be protected
then my perspective on this is pretty
clear I think the children are innocence
to be protected I don't think the
children in teenagers are fully rational
actors and I think that it is adults who
it is the job of adults to stand up
children it is adil its adults jobs to
lead now but the left it says it's alts
aren't leading they aren't leading
that's why we need children to lead know
what the left means is adults aren't
doing what you want them to do and
therefore you want to get a bunch of
sympathetic cute faces to do it listen
my kids are really really cute as I've
said before they have they've been
judged by an objective scale as the
cutest children on planet earth but they
don't get to make policy in my house I
make policy in my house because my kids
are not good policy makers if my kids
were good policy makers and I'd listen
to my son every time he waddles out of
his his bedroom at 8 o'clock at night
waddles over to the the refrigerator
opens it up and then says eye cream eye
cream okay he doesn't get the ice cream
I'm the parent it's bad parenting and is
bad and it's bad adult responsibility
too
to say that children should lead the way
on this stuff again if all if these kids
are capable of making good argument make
the good argument then I'll respect the
argument but not gonna respect your your
authority to make the argument just
because this is why it's so weird like
Nate Silver who is somebody who believes
in expertise he spends his life talking
about why expertise matters he's
somebody who spends his life
analyzing numbers he's very angry
because there was an argument that was
made over at the Federalist about
shooting survivors don't have additional
legitimacy when it comes to public
policy arguments and here's what Nate
Silver Twitty tweeted quote parkland
students aren't credential to talk about
the gun debate is one of the worst takes
of all time especially when it comes
from people who don't have very much
relevant life experience themselves what
relevant life experience is it to
actually see a shooting does that make
your life experiences that make it more
relevant when you make a statistical
argument Nate silver is captain
statistics and yet that all seems to go
out the window when there's a personal
experience that has had personal
experience is not an argument it's an
emotional appeal if we all understand
that then we can with withhold the
emotional appeals and we can we can
stand up to them or we can take them as
they are but to use that as a substitute
for actual logic is really really dumb
now speaking of really really dumb
they're a series of articles over the
last couple of days about homelessness
in California this is something I know a
little bit about because there's a
serious homeless problem in my community
there's a serious homeless problem in
Los Angeles last check I think there are
53 thousand homeless people on the
streets of Los Angeles so basically
Dodger Stadium filled with homeless
people in in the city of Los Angeles in
San
francisco it's it's just horrifying
apparently in San Francisco the NBC Bay
Area investigative unit surveyed 153
blocks of downtown San Francisco in
search of trash needles and feces the
investigation revealed trash littered
across every single block the survey
also found 41 blocks dotted with needles
and 96 blocks
sullied with piles of feces just
beautiful just how glorious it's
wonderful that they've that they've
really done a good job with one of the
most beautiful cities in the world by
littering the needles I mean it's it
again this is happening everywhere I
block from my house right on the street
we saw a needle the other day and that's
because there are homeless people who
are wandering around they're drug users
there's some of them who are drug users
not the overwhelming majority but
certainly a significant percentage of
homeless people are drug users or
alcoholic or mentally ill and there are
bunch of people who are saying in the
richest cities in the world San
Francisco should there be this homeless
problem a couple of things to note about
that one if you are a believer that
homeless people are created by the price
of housing then maybe it's the high
level of regulation in San Francisco
that's driving the homeless problem when
you create rent control when you prevent
developers from actually building new
buildings that sends the prices
skyrocketing and that means that if you
are believer that it's people who are on
the fringes people on the economic
margins who end up homeless if that's
your take then you should really be
against regulations with regards to
building new units of housing but folks
on the Left aren't they foolishly cling
to this idea that rent control is going
to somehow bring about cheaper housing
which it never has done anywhere for any
large scale of people only additional
development does that I'm not a believer
that that's what causes the homeless
problem what causes the homeless problem
in my view and there are a number of
good books about mental illness and the
homeless crisis is that in the nineteen
from the nineteen sixties on including
70s and 80s there's been a tremendous
state and local under under funding of
mental health facilities the laws have
been tremendously loosened so people are
not arrested for sleeping on the streets
and they are not put into treatment
facilities if they need treatment
instead they're left just be on the
streets the ACLU has actually sued to
allow people to keep their stuff on the
streets in Los Angeles so there's been
judges in the state of California of
course who have suggested that you have
a state and federal constitutional right
to sleep on the streets in Los Angeles
and then we wonder why this
are littered with feces and needles
that's why when you leave mentally ill
people on the streets when you leave
people who are drug addicts on the
streets you end up with poop and drugs
on the streets that's just something
that happens and it is not mean or cruel
to people who are mentally ill to
suggest that they ought to be given
treatment that they need the whole point
of a functioning of public is that we
are seeking to allow people rational
choice when you are not in your rational
mind you cannot make good choices when
you are a drug-addled person you cannot
make rational choices when you are a
mentally ill person a severely mentally
ill person living on the street these
are not good choices in a very high
percentage the studies vary but a very
high percentage by every study of people
who are living on the streets are
mentally ill and/or drug addicts and yet
the laws have been specifically
constructed by the left to allow those
people to live in their own filth on the
streets it is not good for them it is
not good for the society it's not good
overall this is a result of bad left
policy not just poverty left wants to
make it about communism as though there
are no homeless people in communist
societies it's not about that it's about
bad policy that is happening in our
nation's democratic cities which is
where the vast majority of homeless
people are living at this point okay so
time for a couple of things that I like
and then some things I hate and and then
we will do a federalist paper since we
did not do one yesterday so things I
like so I am currently reading biography
at Andrew Carnegie by David NASA Andrew
Carnegie was at one point the wealthiest
person in the United States which is to
say probably on earth in one of the
great industrialists and all the myths
about him as a robber baron who decided
to give back to the poor after as he was
old and dying that's not true from the
time that he was middle-aged he knew he
wanted to give away all his wealth which
is why the Carnegie Endowment is so
large is why there's Carnegie Hall it's
why their libraries named after Andrew
Carnegie it demonstrates again that just
because you become wealthy doesn't mean
that you become non-virtuous now the way
that he got his wealth is a little more
controversial so Carnegie was involved
with a lot of insider deals he got
wealthy the way a lot of people got
wealthy in the in the Gilded Age which
is to say that he got a bunch of insider
contracts from government connected
players I'm not in favor of that sort of
cronyism obviously but the the
historical read on Carnegie is that he
was a bad man a cruel man at the end of
his life he had sort of a Scrooge like
reformation and decided to give away his
money that's not factually true about
ography is quite good
David Nassau Andrew Carnegie I check out
the book okay other things that I like
so Fergie has now apologized for her
version of the national anthem
she says I've always been honored and
proud to perform the national anthem and
last night I wanted to try something
special for the NBA I'm a risk taker
artistically but clearly this rendition
didn't strike the intended tone I love
this country and honestly tried my best
okay well that's um that's fair
that's fair you know I got enjoyment out
of it I'll say that I found it hilarious
and enjoyable it was it was less about
being disrespectful to me than just
being bad but good for Fergie for at
least recognizing that they anthem that
she sang was garbage so kudos there okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
so the controversy over Laura Ingraham
continues as I said yesterday this is a
deeply intellectually dishonest
conversation Laura Ingraham said to
LeBron James shut up and dribble she
literally wrote a book called shut up
and sing okay this is fifteen years ago
this has been part of her stick for a
very long time when she says that
celebrity should shut up and do whatever
it is that they do what she's saying is
that we don't really think that your
opinion matters very much not that you
have to shut up nothing you don't have a
right to speak but that why would we
take your opinion that seriously if you
don't have any expertise on on the issue
yet the entire media decided that it was
time to call her a bigot on this basis
so Kevin Durant the star player for the
Golden State Warriors he says that this
was racist he says quote like I said our
president made it cool for people to
kind of speak their truth and kind of
show what they're really about it's cool
to uncover that now so we know what's
coming we know if we use our voice and
it's not what some people may agree with
of course they're gonna say ignorant
things like that but we are the American
dream we come from nothing we rose up in
our profession to be able to take care
of our families forever all of which is
fair but then he says I kind of feel
sorry for her because she's not looking
through the lens of being free and what
that's about it feels bad that she
doesn't know what we came from or who we
are personally she might actually enjoy
being around us but might actually feel
inspired by being not just too Brown
around me or LeBron but guys in our
position anybody of color who has risen
up and done something positive in life
again this is putting some accusations
on Laura Ingraham that do not exist I'm
sure that Laura Ingraham knows a lot of
black people I'm sure she would enjoy
hanging out with a lot of NBA players
I'm sure I would enjoy hanging out with
a lot of NBA players they seem like
pretty cool folks some of them but that
doesn't mean they have any political
expertise or that if I criticized LeBron
James for not knowing what he's talking
about
that's that somehow racists take Michael
Wilbon was doing the same thing
on ESPN he's a columnist for The
Washington Post and he says that that
Laura Ingraham comes off like a bigot I
know I shut up in Drupal I realized she
was playing off the title of something
whether it's a book or lecture whatever
she's getting but shut up and dribble
you take yourself that seriously you're
that smart it's interesting in all these
again uber conservatives to talk about
how what stable geniuses they are but
yet they sound like morons when they try
and dictate to other people what they
should talk about what they're
intelligent enough to talk about and she
comes off like a bigot I don't know her
I don't know her work I turn to
frantically off Fox's as I can okay well
if you don't know her you don't know her
work and why are you calling her a bigot
and she says she comes off like a bigot
and then he acknowledges at the very
beginning of that statement that Laura
Ingraham wrote a book called shut up and
sing about the Dixie Chicks who are as
white as white can be now I will say
that they're a bunch of people on the
right who say why should celebrities
have opinions on politics and then when
it's kid rock running for Senate then
suddenly they're fine with it that's
silly
there are people on the Left who are
doing the same thing by the way they're
saying you know that Kid Rock running
for Senate super crazy why would he do
that and now today a Drudge Report he's
linking to showbiz for him one George
Clooney is talking about running for
president apparently apparently he's
gonna they're gonna speak he and his
wife Amal are gonna appear at the March
for our lives he says that only kids
will be speaking at the event but he's
gonna show up anyway and then he says
what I like to be the next president oh
that sounds like fun
can I just had like anybody to be the
next president of the United States
right away please
and Clooney took in an Iraqi refugee
last September in Kentucky the refugees
now a student at the University of
Chicago and and so there's a good case
to be made that they're gonna try and
push George Clooney or some other
celebrity into the presidency listen I'm
not happy with these the merge of
celebrity and politics I think it's it's
backwards I think that celebrity when
people take people's fame as a measure
of their of their aptitude that's
foolish one of the great lines in
Fiddler on the Roof the musical fiddler
on the roof is Tevye's he's talking in
man he's saying about if you were rich
and then people would come to him they'd
ask him questions that would cross a
rabbis eyes and he says and it's a and
it would not matter if I answer right or
wrong when you're rich they think you
really know okay the same thing is true
about Fame in the United States when
you're famous people think you actually
know what you're talking about
usually when you're famous for something
that doesn't mean that you know anything
about any other topic I'm not an
astrophysicist Neil
Tyson knows more about astrophysics than
I do by the same token Neil deGrasse
Tyson is not a politician and he doesn't
know anything about politics and when he
speaks about politics he sounds like a
doof
so areas of expertise do matter okay
quick Federalist paper we didn't do it
yesterday so we are on federalist 16
Alexander Hamilton continuing to talk
about the insufficiency of the Articles
of Confederation and why they should be
replaced by the Constitution he says
confederacies tends to devolve into
civil war because there's not a strong
enough centralized government if the if
there's not enough that the federal
government does if it's basically just
there then the only way to enforce the
rules is with a large standing army
whereas if there's a broad broad federal
government with large pockets of
agreement then people actually have a
stake in the in the preservation of that
government and he says when this he says
if a confederacy breaks down into civil
war then it's gonna get really bloody
now remember all of this is 80 years
before the Civil War are 70 years before
the Civil War and it all comes true says
when once the sword is drawn the
passions of men observed no bounds of
moderation the suggestions of wounded
pride the instigations of irritated
resentment would be apt to carry the
states against which the arms of the
Union were exerted to any extremes
necessary to avenge the affront or avoid
the disgrace of submission he said the
first war of this kind would probably
terminate in a dissolution of the Union
of course it very nearly did he also
said States cannot be trusted to do the
work of the federal government so if you
were to have a confederacy where you'd
say the federal government will pass a
law and then won't have any federal
bodies any federal bureaucracy any
federal forces in the states to enforce
those then the states will just ignore
them the states will just not enforce
those laws and then it'll be very hard
to enforce them because what he can do
invade a state to force it to abide by
federal law better that you should have
an independent federal government that
can enforce its own sphere of law and
then if a state impedes that then you
actually have a conflict as opposed to a
state just refusing to enforce federal
law that's a distinction that still has
some relevance for today's
constitutional law particularly when it
comes to the the federal government
roping States into doing their work for
them
alrighty we will be back here at
tomorrow from Washington DC where we are
headed for a CPAC I ran out of time
talking about CPAC I'll hopefully talk
about a little bit tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing